ONARDT IS OUT FRONT
THIS EXCLU ATH
WEIGHS HOW RT THES HE
ANSTY  L RORINLIGNOULES NGRO ULT
FRLIEEWEteR TEBOTTS THOUNT S
N  CSEONTHATABBTAN T
THPOTE
BFI H
TIE D TETOINWHNT O>>EYICLERCKR
D ORIFep UNKALTE INO I
Y UN TSECNN PEHE
RTGOEEANNI'SHENE ARU 1 EAI
CIE E STWA. TTERUING  T A
ATADE,
GETOorRLKRR MO I BA CH
IT
AN OUT GE
D,
HE
N,FIREOP IR
VE
UPERFLRT.G STONREVI
ORDE
A INSUY COUr:NI.JOLOERRMDEDARON
A PRSIPITELLLIST.ANN Y G G
E  P SDIOF
U
RA
ONUSE INTIT..ANT N GINEIN AT ITI
RE RMITOARG ANERPT
VERE T
NK
RLOEDVEG Y CKTANSIONTENNKNTKE
HEINITRTWA HANIOUN.. AOSICLY U,
ATSTINYSAVN, IBL A
IGE F E T.
HE ANF G IOS RO SETCEIAANUS ML,
IFTEAT
D AT
BLUATHO HOHEATTIREO PTERKITOHE
F  SE.NN
E IGSTEL I SEE TEE.LL IONSTS IOW
. AON
IGBRPEERLIRA
RE WWHES  OEDCEN.HEMAOR
UTINRS HTENI
FIALONANSTTUIC
00ES>>CA
KIALIA
9  AGE A YN P
OFNTER LL